Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres comment devient-on un
criminel un délinquant comment
descendons aux enfers est-ce que nous
sommes tous coupables comme le pensait
par exemple le personnage principal de
la chute de Camus ou bien est-ce qu'il y
a une part pour la responsabilité
individuelle pour le libre arbitre
est-ce que le monde est entièrement
corrompu marqué par le péché par le
mensonge où est-ce qu'il y a une place
pour le salut et pour le bien c'est
autour de ces questions que
tournent nos deux écrits vins nos deux
les deux écrits veineux que nous avons
invités pour cette émission que nous
avons intitulé l'enfer et le paradis
Colomb Schneck bonsoir bonsoir
Colombes vous êtes journaliste mais vous
êtes surtout écrivain vous avez publié
une quinzaine de d'ouvrages
principalement des romans et souvent à
caractère autobiographique et seront
librairie mensonges au Paradis chez
Grasset dans lequel la narratrice
revient sur le home d'enfants elle
passait ses vacances jeunes filles pour
découvrir finalement que ce monde
n'était pas aussi innocent qu'elle le
croyait mais nous allons commencer avec
constance de Bray bonsoir constance
constance vous publiez
offense chez Flammarion
c'est votre quatrième roman et il est je
dois dire très fort très beau très
puissant vous avez commencé votre vie
professionnelle comme avocate pénaliste
et brillante de surcroît puisque vous
avez été élu par vos pères à la
Conférence du stage c'est-à-dire l'élite
du Parrot parisien et cette expérience
nourrit on va en parler sans doute à
nourrice sans doute au fond ce qui est
en quelque sorte un voyage à l'intérieur
du crâne d'un jeune assassin ordinaire
alors ça s'inscrit dans une tradition
littéraire des récits de cette nature je
suis sûr que vous les avez lu j'ai en
particulier pensé d'une part à
L'Étranger de Camus et d'autre part au
journal d'un voleur de Jean Genet à la
fois en raison de la modalités
d'écriture mais aussi de la vision du
monde que vous que vous exposez sur
laquelle nous allons revenir mais donc
vous racontez l'assassinat par un jeune
homme de 19 ans qui vit dans une cité
HLM de sa
AGL de 80 ans une dame qui vit seule
brouillée avec les siens
re racontez-nous à grands trait
l'intrigue en quelque sorte qui
sous-tend se récit oui c'est en quelque
sorte un rascolnikov
contemporain
c'est à dire c'est un jeune homme qui
[Musique]
va tuer sa voisine non pas par un
immosité particulière mais
poussé par un syndrome de circonstances
il va l'avoir pour
la volée parce qu'il est acculé par un
dealer et
puis les choses se passent pas comme
comme prévu et ils valent
soit pareil d'un couteau qui traîne sur
la table et et tu es 10 coups de couteau
comme rascolnikov tu la vieilles à coup
de hache voilà et c'est pardon je vous
en prie je vous en prie c'est juste une
petite session c'est parti d'un fait
divers réel ou c'est une purée de votre
imagination
c'est parti moi je manque je n'ai aucune
imagination ou le réel
en fait c'est une comment dire le réel
est une grille de lecture sans fin du
réel voilà permet de moi je ne cesse de
regarder le réel et d'essayer de voir ce
que je vois et donc ce fait mais je l'ai
choisi je faisais cette histoire pour sa
simplicité parce qu'elle est presque
pureté parfaite si je veux dire dans
dans son dans sa tragédie et dans ce
cette chose qui se répète sans fin alors
ce jeune homme il est il a toutes les
malchances et tous les malheurs sociaux
il a tous les comme on dit dans les
journaux tous les handicaps sociaux
possible
oui alors ça comme c'est à peu près
toujours le cas
de
très souvent le cas c'est pas pour
daigner leur responsabilité de ceux qui
se retrouvent devant les tribunaux mais
il est il est il a une famille déchirée
il est pas le fils de son père sa mère
c'est à dire que c'est pas c'est comment
dire c'est c'est le le duretés la dureté
ordinaire de millions de gens enfin je
sais pas c'est pas du tout sa vie n'est
pas sordide elle est juste
affreuse mais c'est le affreux ok de
beaucoup beaucoup de gens vous avez un
procédé d'écriture qui joue énormément
pour la puissance de votre livre bon
d'abord on a aucun prénom aucun nom mais
et alors qu'il y a de nombreux
personnages on n'est jamais perdu mais
surtout le narrateur le statut du
narrateur est flou en bivalent et mobile
c'est à dire que par moment c'est une
longue confession ou un long monologue
par moment on sait le monologue dans la
langue de ces jeunes assassins et par
d'autres à d'autres moments c'est plutôt
un narrateur cultivé qui prend la si tu
étonne et Blaise Pascal et qui prend la
défense le parti de ce jeune homme oui
qu'on appelle dans sa tête en fait j'ai
un narrateur qui se promène
effectivement où vous l'avez vu qui par
moment décrit les faits et par moment
donc ça c'est généralement c'est à la
troisième personne et puis par moment il
y a un jeu qui est qui est juge je
dirais de l'écrivain c'est-à-dire c'est
comment dire c'est la part d'humanité
que moi je vois dans l'autre et qu'on
voit en l'occurrence dans ce garçon et
il me semble que l'écrivain
non seulement le droit mais l'obligation
de prendre en charge la totalité de
l'expérience humaine et donc je ne prive
pas de d'aller à cet endroit parce que
quelqu'un qui est coupable et quelqu'un
qui est accusé me semble parle de nous
c'est l'avocat d'ailleurs l'avocat se
confond de ce point de vue avec écrit là
parce que le récit prend le parti prend
le point de vue mais du côté prend le
parti de ce jeune assassin est d'abord
parce que il décrit les
conditions matérielles les conditions de
d'abandon à la fois de difficultés
matérielles et d'abandon psychologique
qui sont d'ailleurs produites par les
conditions matérielles et qui pousse au
crime
oui ça c'est pas moi qui me dit enfin je
vais dire c'est d'abord c'est totalement
factuel je l'invente rien et ça il
suffit d'aller passer cinq minutes dans
une dans un dans une salle d'audience
pour voir ce que c'est
alors après ce que je suis son avocat
non parce que
la question c'est la question c'est
notre lien à tous Voilà et je crois
qu'il y a le il le jeu il y a aussi du
nous et c'est en quoi ce qui se passe
quand quelqu'un tu quelqu'un d'autre
quand quelqu'un est jugé en quoi nous ce
cet acte là nous concerne tous d'une
façon collective et aussi chacun de
façon
très personnelle vous citiez Camus dans
la chute c'est tout à fait ça et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai pensé
au journal d'un volant en fait j'ai
pensé plutôt je pense que j'ai pensé
aussi à ce que Sartre disait du journal
d'un voleur il disait c'est une
cosmogonie c'est une représentation du
monde c'est une vision du monde et
d'ailleurs votre narrateur a à travers
ce crime une vision du monde c'est à
dire qu'il représente le monde comme une
série de cercles il y a le cercle
inférieur qui sont ceux qui sont
condamnés à la faute condamnée au mal
condamné au crime et qui d'ailleurs
seront sanctionnés en dessous par la
prison et puis il y a au-dessus nous le
monde supérieur qui vit bien qui vit le
bien parce que précisément il y a ce
cercle inférieur qui lui permet comme
une soupape de sûreté c'est ça la vision
que le narrateur produit à partir du
crime en tout cas c'est ce que moi je
c'est ce que moi je crois oui je pense
que je pense que
nous qui nous parlons ce soit ce soir ou
[Musique]
devant quelque part notre confort à
la France des autres
[Musique]
quelque chose qui me voilà d'instinctif
et en tout cas qu'on est qu'on est
responsable de ce qu'on ne veut pas voir
et qui a une forme de naïveté bien
confortable à croire que ce qu'il se
passe dans les tribunaux que le mal
qu'on ne commet pas
n'est pas notre affaire mais si vous
avez même presque une vision christique
du crime c'est à dire que votre assassin
il est là je vous avais dû avoir je sais
pas si vous avez eu ou pas une éducation
chrétienne profonde mais si vous l'avez
pas eu elle vous avait été infusée parce
que votre assassin il est là pour porter
nos péchés pour porter le mal le mal est
dans le monde et il y a une catégorie de
gens les pauvres les dominés qui sont là
pour porter ce mal et pour que nous nous
ayons le sentiment de faire les biens il
y a une espèce de il va mourir pour nous
il va souffrir pour nous il va commettre
des crimes pour nous mais est-ce que en
faisant ça vous
en tout cas votre narrateur ne
l'absolvez pas de ces crimes est-ce
qu'il y a pas quand même une liberté de
faire le bien ou mal est-ce qu'il y a
pas une responsabilité individuelle
est-ce qu'il y a pas un libre arbitre
est-ce qu'on est absolument
prédéterminé aux crimes par les
conditions sociales de son existence
je fais semblant quoi liberté
et un vieux débat entre les jansénistes
et jésuites sur la question de la grâce
les Jésuites parce que pour des raisons
aussi politiques
prétendait que
[Musique]
qui croyait à la liberté disait que
qu'on peut se qu'on n'a pas besoin de la
grâce pour pour sentir
les gens sénistes évidemment beaucoup
plus pessimistes
disait que la grâce était absolument
nécessaire c'était la grasse nécessaire
ou la grâce suffisante
je crois qu'on fait comme on peut et que
certains peuvent moins que d'autres
c'est tout
et je partage avec Jeunet au-delà de la
question de la cosmogonie
cette technique c'est une technique du
renversement du stigmate c'est à dire de
faire des pêcheurs des seins et c'est
aussi c'est aussi ce que ce que fait ce
qu'a fait le christianisme c'est pour ça
que
je crois non pas ce qui m'intéresse en
christianisme c'est la grille de lecture
du monde qu'il fait et qui me paraît
juste
offenses de constance de brèche chez
Flammarion c'est un texte je l'ai dit
c'est un texte très fort
parce que avec une technique narrative
et un style très original très puissant
vous sublimez un fait divers vous
montrer non seulement la banalité du mal
mais l'humanité des monstres qui sont
nos frères
alors chez vous Colombes Schneck
mensonge au paradis il est aussi
question de paradis il est aussi
question de déréliction de descente aux
enfers mais alors pas du tout dans le
même décor et disons d'une manière moins
tragique donc mensonge au paradis c'est
le récit on va commencer par là de
dimensions plus ou moins
autobiographique vous expliquer à quel
point vous troublez l'autobiographie
donc effectivement c'est vous montez
quand même vous la voulez donc le décor
de ce de ce récit c'est un chalet suisse
un peu idyllique à la montagne qui est
un home d'enfants
j'ai passé toute mon enfance de moi par
an de l'âge de 5 ans à 20 ans dans une
vallée qui me paraissait barathisiaque
on fait comme on peut comme disait
constance et le comme on peut c'était
cette vallée
mes parents pour différentes raisons que
j'ai longtemps voulu ignorer ne pouvait
pas s'occuper de nous ne pouvait pas
être présent dans le
vous pouvez pas être présent au monde
dans ce qui était une vie quotidienne
ils étaient retenus dans leur passé et
ça je l'ignorais enfant j'étais persuade
grandir de façon très heureuse par des
parents aimants mes parents et
m'aimaient de façon à contestable mais
je me souviens pas de ma mère mais
embrassée ou toucher par exemple et donc
on passait je passais deux mois par an
dans cette famille d'adoption en Suisse
où j'étais éduquée de façon assez rigide
assez dur on était beaucoup plus ni au
marché dans la montagne le matin au soir
et c'était pour moi une forme de paradis
vous dites dur mais en même temps le
couple qui tient ce room d'enfant
Anne-Marie et France et qui ont deux
enfants d'ailleurs vous élève à vous
s'occupent de vous avec un mélange
d'autorité mais tout de même de liberté
et surtout de tendresse
de tout ça qu'on marchait beaucoup en
montagne et le père Karl disait on ne
s'arrête jamais
on ne s'arrête pas parce que ça coupe
les jambes et ce côté on s'arrête pas
que ça coupe les gens je pense c'est
rester ancré en moi mais aussi une
attention une affection
des règles qui me qui effectivement qui
me soutiennent encore aujourd'hui mais
vous racontez même vous faites un
parallèle un peu plus tard dans le récit
vous vous revenez sur les carences dont
vous avez souffert parce que vos parents
rescapés de la guerre et ayant subi un
traumatisme n'avait pas forcément de
place pour la tendresse dont vous aviez
besoin et il y avait comme un refuge de
tendresse dans ce home en tout cas c'est
le souvenir que vous en avez deux
refuges j'avais effectivement ce Home et
j'avais la lecture je me souviens
qu'enfant je lisais l'annuaire c'est des
gros bottins je vais passer mes heures à
l'air à rechercher des noms des adresses
dans l'annuaire donc c'est là que je me
que je cherchais quelque chose dont nous
ne parlait pas que je l'entends voulu
ignorer contrairement à Constant je
pense pendant très longtemps je voulais
que les histoires se terminent bien j'ai
cherché je lisais des contes de fées qui
se terminaient bien c'est ce que je
voulais j'espérais que ça se termine
bien j'y vivais un espèce d'esquive de
la réalité dans lequel l'histoire se
terminait elle se marièrent beaucoup
d'enfants ou voilà je voulais absolument
que ça se termine bien et donc je
cherchais désespérément ça se termine
bien et à l'âge de 20 ans j'ai cessé
d'aller dans ce chalet et je suis jamais
retournée parce que j'avais trop peur la
réalité j'avais trop peur d'y aller avec
mes yeux d'adultes et de voir que la
réalité est très injuste très cruelle
très destructrice et
qu'on découvre qu'on vous revenez 30 ans
après dans ce chalet pour enquêter sur
ces souvenirs d'enfance on s'aperçoit
que ce couple Anne-Marie et Karl et
leurs enfants
pas tout et Vava
sont c'est pas le c'est pas la famille
tout rose que vous aviez imaginé ils
sont même assez dysfonctionnel en fait
quand je retourne dans cette vallée il y
a 4-5 ans j'ai retrouvé les paysages
intactes la grande beauté de ces
paysages de ces montagnes et j'avais
l'idée je suis rentrée à Paris en disant
je vais créer un roman Suisse à un roman
de chapitre vert du sucre blanc ça sera
très charmant joli quoi ça sera
mais très vite j'apprends que
effectivement que Patou est en prison il
a été arrêté l'enterrement de son père
c'est un délinquant et c'est un escroc
il a passé sa vie à mentir et à voler et
que sa sœur va va extrêmement malade
elle fait des délires paranoïa qu'elle
enfermé chez elle réécrire les évangiles
et
il y a mensonge au Paradis Anne-Marie
trompait son mari
non mais c'est loin de son mari était un
tyran de mystique enfin
ce qui m'intéresse
sont morts ce qui m'intéressait ce qui
me c'était la souffrance actuelle
pourquoi les deux enfants que j'en viens
enfin je rêvais de vivre avec eux dans
ce chalet toute l'année plutôt quand on
est à Paris pourquoi ces enfants
vivaient au pays des mensonges pourquoi
ils étaient tellement détruits
et j'ai voulu tenter de comprendre ne
pas le juger pas tout
pas tout à délinquant qui a détruit
beaucoup de choses autour de lui mais
surtout sa vie à lui qu'est-ce qui lui
est arrivé et c'est de comprendre
une tentative de comprendre
sans jugement avec l'amour que je le
porte
comment on devient des langues comment
on vole comment on prend on devient un
mentor et un voleur mais au passage vous
revisitez votre propre existence parce
que vous racontez vous confesser que
vous-même
vous revenez sur vos relations avec les
hommes je ferai pas de jeux de moule à
canyon sur Home et home mais vous et
vous racontez comment notamment votre
premier financé vous êtes embarqué dans
une histoire dans lequel lui descendait
aux enfers
alcoolisait se détruisait et essayer de
vous détruire aussi donc vous faites un
parallèle entre les illusions du bonheur
du du Chalet du Home et vos propres
illusions dans vos relations avec vos
parents dans vos relations avec les
hommes
que je fais c'est l'esquive de la de la
réalité on fait comme on peut
mais pendant longtemps je faisais pas
comme on peut je faisais je j'arrangeais
l'histoire
je ne voulais pas voir que je ne voulais
voir que le côté que le bon côté des
choses
[Musique]
j'ai relu ce livre de Clément Rossell le
philosophe Clément Rosset qui s'appelle
le réel et son double et il l'écrit on
se ment tous il prend l'exemple de
courte lignes de d'une pièce qui
s'appelle mouroche ou c'est la main qui
refuse de voir l'amour qu'elle soit dans
le placard parce que c'est de la réalité
trop cruelle pour lui il dit on fait
tout ça on refuse de voir la manque à
challenge placard refuse de voir la
vérité on refuse de voir la souffrance
on refuse de voir d'aller au tribunal
voir ceux qui vont être jugés pour leurs
crimes parce que on préfère parce qu'il
faut un coeur des reins pour accepter la
réalité
et il y a eu un moment où j'étais prête
mes parents sont morts et bien morts
j'ai vécu des 7 oui des formes de
violence verbale assez forte que je
refusais d'entendre il y a eu un moment
où je me suis levé je me suis levé et
j'étais capable de lire de voir et d'ENT
la vérité alors vous aussi au fond il y
a un peu comme dans le livre de
constance de monnaie à moins explicite
mais tout de même une cosmogonie un
récit sur le monde une vision du monde
alors vous c'est un monde
de mensonges le bonheur est une illusion
complète tout et mensonge et tout est
c'est à dire que entre le jansénisme de
constance de Bray avec le péché originel
qui corrompt le monde et votre
pessimisme ashkénaze qui fait que nous
sommes dédiés aux malheur avec le
malheur et le bonheur est une illusion
on entre vous deux franchement on est
vernis
je suis pas d'accord je je
pense pas avoir une vision aussi noire
au contraire je pense de voir la réalité
c'est de d'être capable de voir la
beauté de ces paysages de voir revoir
d'entendre l'affection que j'ai reçu en
fond la tendresse je ne suis pas
d'accord j'ai une vision effectivement
je suis capable de voir la noirceur
enfin parce qu'elle existe je suis
capable de voir l'injustice parce qu'il
existe de faire avec mais je n'oublie
pas et
moi j'entends plus pas la tendresse la
beauté et l'affection et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a aussi mon paradis il y a des
il y a plein de formes de mensonges je
suis une menteuse moi-même je me mens
pour voilà pour mais je crois qu'il ne
partent de Paradise qu'on peut être
racheté vous pensez vous vous avez cette
vision je suis sûr que Colomb mais
beaucoup plus optimiste que moi quand
j'ai besoin que le mal soit dit pour
pour croire au bien mais je voudrais
rassurer quand même ceux qui nous
suivent aucun de ces deux livres ne nous
plonge dans la dépression au contraire
ce sont des livres qui nous élèvent on
va poursuivre cette conversation mais on
va le faire avec un lecteur qui va nous
poser une question je crois que la
question est pour Colombe et le lecteur
s'appelle Arthur Arthur c'est à vous
[Musique]
bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle Arthur
Manceau j'ai 21 ans et je suis étudiant
en deuxième année à la centrale duelec
j'aime beaucoup les la lecture de roman
assez moderne souvent des petits textes
assez courts et percutants donc une
lecture qui m'a marqué dernièrement
c'est les choses de Georges Perec donc
déjà et on fait des études en
mathématiques j'aime beaucoup Pérec et
le fait qu'ils mettent pas mal de
mathématiques dans ces textes alors il
engrais spécialement dans les choses
mais c'est un livre qui m'a tenu en
haleine du début à la fin c'est pas très
long mais on le lit avec enfin je trouve
qu'il arrive à mettre beaucoup de
suspense dans ce livre alors que
pourtant c'est un livre qui est quand
même un récit narratif ou à la fin il se
passe pas grand chose et on n'arrive pas
vraiment une conclusion
et donc j'ai beaucoup aimé cet aspect là
d'ailleurs c'est un aspect qu'on
retrouve un peu dans mensonge au Paradis
donc bonjour Colomb Schneck
donc ma question que j'aimerais vous
poser par rapport à votre livre c'est
que dedans vous faites une introspection
de votre passé et on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup de douleurs dans le processus
d'écriture donc je voulais vous demander
si vous pensez que la douleur
elle est elle est féconde dans le
processus d'écriture et est-ce qu'elle
est nécessaire pour pour faire un récit
autobiographique on met ce qu'il faut de
la douleur pour écrire je crois pas
j'écris pas dans la douleur j'écris j'ai
eu longtemps normal à écrire ce livre
parce que je ne voyais pas j'allais je
voulais écrire sur ce paradis je
refusais de voir les mensonges il y
avait de la colère un moment
il y a une ignorance je dirais pas que
il y a de la douleur je suis quelqu'un
quand je suis dans mon livre je suis
assez heureuse je maîtrise mon monde je
suis dans mon monde et je c'est un
endroit dans lequel je suis bien et vous
vous pensez que la douleur nourrit le
travail de l'écrivain non je pense que
le travail de l'écrivain et du travail
dans la douleur c'est difficile et qui
qui rend je pense heureux mais en tout
cas le plaisir de que fait que donne le
travail en tout cas vous donnez l'une et
l'autre beaucoup de plaisir à votre
lecteur cette émission
s'achève mais pas complètement parce que
je vais vous demander de bien vouloir
partager avec ceux qui nous suivent
votre coup de cœur de la semaine le
livre dont vous avez envie qu'il le lise
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut qu'il y ait un Huawei effect
comme on dit en bon français du côté de
ceux qui nous suivent quand ils vont
lire le livre que vous leur proposez
colombe on commence par vous moi je suis
maîtrise de Perec donc du coup quand la
biographie de Perec est sortie vous avez
de Claude bourgeonnaz je me suis
précipitée parce que je j'avoue que je
les vois le matériel je voulais voir je
suis quand je libérais que j'ai
l'impression que de lire sur moi ma
famille et et j'ai appris dans ce
biographique qui était à grand
parachutiste
aussi un soldat en parachutiste qu'il
avait soufflé des sauts en parachute et
j'imaginais pareil que le petit gros que
mon père son corps et en fait non il
s'était en parachute et il y a d'autres
choses dans ce livre mais ça m'a frappé
parce que c'est évidemment un immense
écrivain je vais prendre l'homme qui
dort qui est un livre très très court et
qui est aussi
politique entre tout l'art de Perec et
dans le justement dans ce qui n'est pas
dit dans le creux que que les choses
dont parlait notre lecteur
dans la mesure où c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune homme qui va progressivement
s'arrêter voilà il va un jour ne pas
aller un examen et puis et puis ne pas
il va ne pas ne pas ne pas ne pas
sans qu'on sache d'ailleurs si c'est
une scie s'approche de la mort si c'est
une dépression ou tout à coup au
contraire un acte de liberté et une
prise de conscience totale en tout cas
c'est très beau très bien alors Georges
Perec fait partie des choix de la
rédaction de Benoît des livres à travers
cette géographique a été écrit non
seulement par quelqu'un qui le connaît
on adore George Perry qu'ici non
seulement qu'il connaît bien qui connaît
bien son œuvre mais qu'il a connu
personnellement qui était l'un de ses
amis vous l'avez eu cette biographie je
vous l'offre marin de virer c'est un
jeune roi il peut plus si jeune que ça
écrivain SCI alors tout à fait
réactionnaire mais le talent n'a pas de
frontière un partisane c'est une espèce
de fils naturelle de George de de
Houellebecq et de Nimier et il fait une
satire de la société Germano pratique du
monde de l'art contemporain et des
médias c'est très amusant manchette
manchette ce sont les entretiens de
manchettes manchette c'est un auteur de
polar qui a révolutionné le polar
français en le faisant venir à ses
racines à mettre en fait et qui qui a
ressourcé complètement le polar français
il a inventé le néopolar et c'est un
type extrêmement intéressant
joueur de musiciens de jazz amateur de
Guy Debord tout à fait original
et ses entretiens sont très intéressants
je sens que ça vous intéresse aussi
enfin matmaden exhibri c'est un auteur
de bande dessinée américain mais qui est
toute très original lui aussi il avait
c'est lui qui avait traduit
graphiquement l'exercice de style de que
nous il poursuit dans cette veine les
exercices de style avec exclibris qui
est publié chez l'association c'est un
c'est extrêmement intéressant du point
de vue du dessin et du projet j'ai senti
que votre client je vous l'offre voilà
cette émission est terminée merci de
l'avoir suivi merci à Colomb Schneck et
à Constance Debré merci à notre lecteur
Arthur vous pouvez nous revoir soit sur
le site de Public Sénat soit sur votre
plateforme préférée et sinon nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine à la
même heure à moins que d'ici là nous ne
nous soyons croisés dans une librairie
merci et bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]